I think that it's going to demonstrate
but I think that actually one of the
best things that ever happened to me was
to not have any kind of early success
when I first started auditioning I
auditioned for two years without ever
getting a job and two years they want a
lot of auditions it's a lot of being
told no no um and that's hard to take
but I think that the longer that you
want something and don't get it but are
able to withstand that kind of um
rejection and still say that this is
you'd still say that this is what you
want to do the stronger that it makes
you and the more able you are to whether
the inevitable ups and downs which
really is just the life of an actor
because there is no consistency and
there is no security at any time you're
always thinking you know where is my
next job where is your going to come
from what am I going to do every movie
that you make always seems like it's the
biggest influence at the time because
it's always like the last thing that you
did so it's like the thing that was most
recently challenging you so I never feel
like any movie that I've made is more
important than another movie but
probably like that yeah yeah they're all
kind of they're all sort of equal even
the bad ones really like that's another
kind of interesting lesson to learn
along the way that the things that I've
done that haven't turned out well are
just as important as the things that
I've done that have turned out well
because they are there they're equally
instructive teachers I never know
exactly what like when I when I first
read something I never know exactly why
I'm attracted to something I just know
that I am it's kind of like when you
meet somebody and you don't really know
anything about them yet but your heart
just kind of like goes to them and you
realize like oh I sort of have a crush
on this person that's kind of how I feel
like about parts that I play a movie
that I make like I don't know exactly
why I'm drawn to something at first
then I started a kind of process of
trying to figure that out but to begin
with I don't know why something moves me
or doesn't move me it's just that my
heart goes to it or it doesn't acting is
really lonely when you just think about
it as yourself but if you think about it
as being in the scene with someone it's
really um fulfilling and and really
being open to another person like really
allowing yourself to take in what
they're saying and to be affected by
what the you know the infant estimate
changes and like their choices in a
scene to really kind of to really listen
it can fit probably like to not be
afraid to show them things to not be
afraid to bring them ideas to not be
embarrassed to not be shy and to risk
embarrassment because like what's the
worst thing that can happen like you
have a bad idea and you share it with
somebody like if you're not going to die
from that and chances are it might be
get it might be whittled in to something
that like then is a good idea so if
anything that I've learned there's
anything that I've really learned or
anything that I would want like somebody
else to not have to learn the hard way
it's to just like raise your hand and
like use your voice and shout out your
opinion and like let's come what may
[Music]
[Music]